foreign
inside a building where a weekly Bible
study meeting was taking place
outside a stream of police vehicles and
ambulances rushes to the scene
yeah
I'm a resident up here and I heard loud
gunshots so I went to the window to get
an idea of the situation then I saw that
a man was shooting out of the window
with a firearm there were people being
carried out and there were probably 25
shots at least that I heard and after
the police got there there was no
gunfire for a long time then after five
minutes or so there was a single shot
on police then stormed the building
escorting people out
police say a body found on the upper
part of the building may have been the
gunman
the police officers who went in found
people who may have been seriously
injured by Firearms some of them facily
the officers also heard a shot from the
upper part of the building and went
upstairs where they also found a person
so far we have no indications that any
perpetrators fled
forensic teams are looking for Clues as
police investigate the kanman's motives
foreign